um makes you want to do it more yeah you
know you know what I mean like even like
alcohol like that makes me want to drink
it more based on the fact that you
probably shouldn't and that was illegal
and look at how much the Mafia profited
because it was illegal you know and it
all goes back to money right so like and
they legalized it because they don't
want to miss out on the tax dollars it's
it's just crazy like I don't understand
why when I bring this up people think
conspiracy or other things and it's kind
of like this so um I'll you even bring
it back to earth where it's like
Hollywood right people think Hollywood
is very racist and I go no they're just
greedy they might be racist I don't know
but I think they're first and foremost
very greedy and so I'm like yeah cuz
they they go where the money goes right
and then lately there's been more
there's more love toward the Asians
right so like they're like oh Milan is
finally they're finally Disney's doing
the right move and finally you know like
right movies because it's gonna make
money dude BAM
right you know why cuz the first Moulin
didn't go popular in China they're like
the [ __ ] [ __ ] this story like this is
fake they got a talking dragon and [ __ ]
that's why they wanted to historically
accurate Mulan so China will buy ya the
Avengers [ __ ] made 600 like mil
domestically but - for 2.5 billion
internationally yeah right
so I think they made like dollar for
dollar the same amount in China or some
[ __ ] like they made a [ __ ] ton of money
in China it was like four billion yuan I
don't know and like you know for this
stuff that's you I guess like
progressive in a positive way like I'm
I'm on that wave of like I really do
appreciate it you know but to say that
the reason what for example they they
give credit to Disney you know that
stuff like we're not just Disney let's
just use any company right and they go
dude that's so progressive of them if it
was it wasn't based off of feelings yeah
if it wasn't profitable yeah would it
have [ __ ] done it hell and a period
end of story
and um if it's there's nothing to argue
with that it isn't the business a
hundred percent if everybody was against
it and they knew that they weren't gonna
sell anything with it they wouldn't have
made that move they wouldn't have made
such huge statements about right even in
terms of things that are bought like
body-positive
right if if if everybody was against
Nike selling larger clothing they would
not have done a larger clothing line
where they show a bigger mannequins and
stuff is because everybody is in a good
way - it's a positive thing that is
happening in my personal opinion but to
say that that company made that move
based on a moral decision is a very
shallow way of thinking right because we
all know that American is America is one
of the biggest obese countries in the
world so they're gonna sell all for sure
gym clothes for sure for obese people it
it's you know like what the [ __ ] you
know it's like duh yeah I mean I guess
maybe maybe a lot of people don't see
the world this way so they're hoping
that people are moral and they're like
well there's probably somebody there
that fought for this it maybe that's
true but at the end of the day decisions
are made by companies and politics and
business because of a lot of it is
because of money yeah a lot of it is I
don't want to say all of it you know cuz
there might be like some like let's say
Nike CEOs wife really cared about
something and then she was like you know
honey I don't want this and then he was
like well maybe I'll I'll try to put it
in like that happens too
you know or like their kid is really
like fighting for something and then
they're like dad would you would do this
yeah like that those things happen but
like I think in general if you look at
how things are working it's always tied
to like someone getting paid group
getting paid group benefiting or group
winning you know in some way shape or
form it's never like oh man they don't
want to hire as Asians dude they'll hire
us Asians and us Asians only if we made
a [ __ ] ton of money for them yeah if if
if Asians
if Asian male leads were we're getting
like billions and billions of dollars
like all the time then we would wipe out
the competition and there'll be no other
male leads but us men even goes further
into talking about let's not even
touched on
about on a human level talking about
certain topics in a controversial or
quote-unquote what people say is
controversial yeah it doesn't me just
give the mindset about gives him like
social currency right for example when
we when we first started doing what we
were doing right we just wanted to
represent who we were right and then
during this time there were there wasn't
like too many people like backing us up
saying like oh yeah there are Asian
people like that or whatever there was a
certain amount right yeah that's true
but now the wave is like Asian Americans
need to stand up and all of a sudden
these [ __ ] come out the
woodwork is like yo man I've been
supporting you know Asian man we need to
get more Asian Americans on the screams
like yeah where the [ __ ] were you you
know eight years ago I know and you
weren't there it's easy because you can
do that now because when you write that
on Twitter you get 800 likes a thousand
likes you're getting social currency
from it yeah just on that understanding
you should understand how important it
is or how money works right right if it
works like that on a social level it's
clearly gonna work like that on a
monetary monetary level because back in
the day when it wasn't really cool to
say that you were scared you were just
like no you didn't have the courage yeah
you're looking around your shoulders see
if other people are agreeing with ya so
you you I mean people know that they do
that I see a lot of Asian Americans who
were very quiet before that are now
they're puffing up their chests and they
feel like they can talk now yeah they're
just talking [ __ ] about everybody else
it's like yo men like you weren't there
when it counted the most now it's easy
for you to do that now it's is not
really brave like so this it's like this
it's like in the in the sixties being
that asian guy marching down while
police are [ __ ] like spraying hoses
like water at you and smacking you
around and you're fighting to get the
Asian American Studies
into your University Asians had to do
that [ __ ] right they had to actually
literally fight and lockdown campus I
think it was Berkeley or whatever so we
could have a multicultural Studies
program mm-hmm and it's crazy because
they were having [ __ ] thrown at them for
for doing this and I'm like okay that's
ballsy going on Twitter
and having a few thoughts that to me I
don't care what I don't give a damn how
people say think think about me but I
think that's some [ __ ] [ __ ] well yeah
that is a complete weakness 100% and
what and you know I'm like I love
[ __ ] Twitter dude like Twitter makes
me laugh as a but I love talking [ __ ]
yeah there's some funny [ __ ] on there
you know but when I see some of these
things that people post where they go
you know what you shouldn't treat people
like this because of this oh that's how
you're doing it because you're trying to
see what's that what that emotional
tickets and other people have so you can
get the retweet yeah it's not because
that's a moral stance of yours no you
just try it's like that one one Asian
kid that was that that work that went
viral calling that little white girl in
a Chinese dress he [ __ ] he [ __ ]
talked [ __ ] saying your dress is not my
coat like my culture is not your [ __ ]
costumes or whatever right and then
later people dig up all this [ __ ] he was
using the n-word he was like a hard
[ __ ] are yup he was talking mad [ __ ]
it's like man you ain't about that
[ __ ] act of his life dude is it's so
[ __ ] dumb dude it's funny too cuz we
did that video where we were talking
about the you know the hole who said
Dean Deano and chemo or whatever you
know the the poncho people that they
they were out in [ __ ] Highland Park
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and some people
you know there was like some Mexican
folks they were like oh we don't care
people wear Poncho's and I was like oh
that's cool that's that's understandable
but how you feel about that doesn't mean
that those people who live in those
heavily Mexican areas that are Mexican
they can also feel like they're not cool
with it too yeah you know like you can't
speak for that whole culture I guess I
mean we kind of we all do that sometimes
yeah because we're putting ourselves in
those boots I think the the poncho
wasn't an issue like Poncho's are hot
I've been like the last like two years
ago like Poncho's got really big people
weren't for fashion right yeah but it
wasn't the poncho that was offensive it
was the [ __ ] mustache the sombrero
the [ __ ] oh I don't know what they
were recording yeah they were worried
yeah they're making that I think that
dude in the video was upset because the
guy was trying to profit off of making
fun of Mexican people oh that's what it
was they're always mad about the actual
poncho dude you know what I mean like I
[ __ ] used to wear sombreros all the
time just because they can't get the Sun
out of my head
I mean can I used to get it at the flea
market salon and this I saw a Mexican
folks getting creamed people put all
that all the times I used to like some
bread as well as used to working at this
place is called denials out in
Sacramento I feel like people are just
getting more and more socially stupid
yeah they just don't understand concoct
a context context like I throw this word
around a lot but I just want people to
understand the just words and things are
just like objects or something yes yes
and it there's a feeling attached to
that and you got to read what that means
and it takes time but man it's is just
damn there's so much misunderstandings
going on yeah like for example you know
this is skating summer and it gets hot
there's something that I wear so my a
really good friend of mine named Amen
her mom got me a [ __ ] does she can
when she went to Africa yeah the summer
because it's nice and cool right but I'm
not meant to be in how like hot girl is
and I like the way it feels I like the
way it looks it's dope right and I'm not
going outside wearing a [ __ ] it wearing
the by shiki going how are you today
yeah my name is David hello my name is
Dave what do you want to do today like
I'm not I'm not going out there with an
African accent I'm wearing the the
[ __ ] dashiki because it was a gift
and I like the way it looks at his dope
you know what I mean I'm not mocking the
culture I'm appreciating it right and
even then some people have some [ __ ] to
say to it right they'll be like oh we're
like don't wear that [ __ ] it's like
that's like broad but do you have a
[ __ ] dashiki straight from Africa
give it to me by an African woman you
shut the [ __ ] up she tells me it's okay
I'm gonna [ __ ] wear um you know
that's just crazy so yeah so context
does matter right I did read a lot of